[موسيقى]
نعم
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته حياكم
الله اليوم يوم عادي بالنسبه للكثيرين لكن
في هجوم العلوم فهو يوم مصيري انا اقتربت
الاشتراك المقاعد المخصصه قليله تسع مقاعد
فقط المواجهات مع لجنه التحكيم انتهت لكن
نقاشات الساخنه لمراحل التصفيات الاولى
مستمره نقاشات من نوع اخر تبدا اليوم في
المجلس العلمي اليوم سيتحدد من سيغادر ومن
سيحلق في افاق الابتكار في ضلال المتحف
الاسلامي في الدوحه اجواء المشتركين
مشحونه بالخوف والاعصاب مشدوده والتوتر
عالي جدا مبدعون ينتظرون قرار المجلس
العلمي الذي يعقد الان في المدينه
التعليميه وتحديدا في جامعه جورج تاون في
الخطه شغله النجوم اليوم العالم العربي
سنه برهن انه ما في مستحيل ما فيه
عربيا من كافه انحاء العالم
[تصفيق]
انا شخصيا
بالمرحله القيمه في مصر طبعا انها
بالمجلس العلمي شباب من خبره الوضوح
استيعاب التصفيات العراق ويتطلع بقلق
وحماس الى قرار المجلس العلمي
الاختيار المتميزين منهم مهمه شبه مستحيله
انا بصراحه اليوم محرج وهيك يعني ماني
مرتاح بالموسم التاسع اكثر شي
واحراجا لاي حاجه الكل يستحق التاهل
والاماكن محدوده تسعه فقط ولجنه التحكيم
امام المهمه الاسرى اختيار الافضل
يعين الدكتور خالد تبحثوا في كل الاتجاهات
امس طهران فكروا كانت الحاله اللي في
الاجهزه الطبيه الدكتور ما اعتقد انه نوصل
الطبيب عبد الحميد خليجي هو على المشاريع
الطبيه في
علمي انت تقول
البروفات حبيب والهندسه يدور في الطب
والتكنولوجيا والبيئه تقدم شيء الطبيب بدو
الطبيب وانت الحديث هلا بالمجال الطبي
مقتل سته الخرافات يعني عنده نظريه مشرف
قبل التحرير الجلسه غير عادي يعني بحيلك
برايي واعطاء الفرصه
نقاشات علميه
هل هو بيقدر يتنافس مع اللي حواليه
الحركه التحكيم يكون مشاريع يرتكب يكون ما
بين النخبه وسفير ممتاز بالمستقبل
حدد المتاهلين والنتائج سريه متنفس بلشنا
وبدات هموم اخرى
ثلاثه وثلاثين مشتركا
ام
[موسيقى]
كلنا امبارح بالليل كان عصرنا مش هذه
المرحله
يعني
كثيره
نعم
حرب نفسيه
انا بقول الله يكون المتسابقين اليوم انه
اكيد اعصابهم وكل واحد فيهم طبعا عنده امل
كبير انه يوصل
في اختراق
كمان
ثلاثه وثلاثين مشارك ممتازين
احسن ما كان من التسعه المتسابقين
المسلمين نخبه النخبه اللي بتساعد معاني
هذا الجبل العالي
في شويه توتر يعني ما راح نحكي انه ما فيه
توتر
ان شاء الله يعني الفقه ان شاء الله يعني
يكون فايزين والله احنا سوينا اللي علينا
كل ما كانت النتيجه القنبله
[موسيقى]
اللي بيوصل للتسعه من النخبه ياخذ فرصه
لمده ثلاث شهور ومساعده برنامج معلوم
والقطر منهما ينفذوا اقترحها في مستوى عند
الشعب العربي قادر اختراق بعد اللي يفكر
وكل ما يحتاجه وفرص
القدرات الكبيره اللي حصلت وسقط هايدي
امانه برقبتنا انه نتاكد انه عم تنحط في
المكان الصحيح مع الشخص المناسب للحل
المفيد انا شخصيا من ابناء ولازم يرجع
يكون انا احاول ان يكونوا المعركه
ام
لجنه التحكيم حددت خياراته ونتائج ستقرر
مصير المشتركين من بقي ومن غادر بعد
الفاصل احنا
[موسيقى]
وسائل الاتصال والتواصل تنوعت عبر التاريخ
الهاتف اللاسلكي والانترنت ونقل الرسائل
الخطيه اليوم اخترنا هذه ال وسيله لنقل
البشرى الساره الى ما سيفوز بمقعد في
المجموعه الاولى
الى سريه
ختمت هذه اللجنه
تحدد الان مصير المشتركين
على مهلك
كان في استتباب في النتيجه قبل ثواني كان
فيه حماس
كما تم حول الطاقه المتجدده
في البرلمان يقوم العلوم
لكن
ما نستطيع ان نفقد الامل اه
محمد فرج مطلوب منك ثلاثين اه
ثم افتح المغلفه خاصه
اوكي
[تصفيق]
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
مصطفى شكرا التمرين
قطع نفسي
وحضرتك انقطعت مشاركتك
لا
الحمد لله مبسوط بالنتيجه
[موسيقى]
الافكار القديمه للتدريب الرياضي تفتقر
الى التفاؤليه التي تساعد على تحسين
التدريب
ومحمد فرج يقترح عده الكترونيه لتحديث هذه
ال ال
انا كل حياتك الاصفار من ان او بالمدرسه
[موسيقى]
حد ذاتها يعلمنا على المباراه يعني عملوا
مضبوط
حاله
انا كيف
كثير
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
نعم
ام
وطالب اوراقكم بيضاء لجنه التحكيم الفرصه
لكتابتها خارج من العلوم مشروع
اه في لا تقل عنهم لكن في النهايه لازم
يعرف واحد فينا غسان
النتيجه صارت بيني وبينه
مبروك فؤاد
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
صرنا لهون ايضا جيد وشرف لنا ان شاء الله
نرفع اسم الاثنان بالعالم
ماشيين
كلنا يرتدي ثيابا مختلفه لغايات متعدده
فؤاد يريد بناء اله تستخدم تكنولوجيا
النادي لتصبح فيها المفضله هزيله بالمائه
او مداويه الجروح والالام
[موسيقى]
نانو تكنولوجيا ضروريه كثير ب عصرنا هذا
ويشمل تقريبا كل الاختصاصات اختصاصات
الغذاء
والمنسوجات اختصاصات البيئيه واكيد الطب
والادويه وغيره
كبيره نحو المستقبل لانه عم نقدر ندخل
اللي علم الجزائر الموجود بقلب الخليه ليش
عنده كنا معينه عم بقل بوجود صغيره عم
نغير بتركيب و
بتغيير التركيبه عم نقدر نستفيد من كثير
اشياء تحمينا اكثر من الشمس تتفاعل اكثر
مع الماي فيه عندنا بعض الاقمشه عندها
استعمالات الطبيه والاقمشه الثانيه اللي
كلنا من البسه نقدر نجمع ونعمل يكون
بينسوا بموجبها التكنولوجيا هايدي على
كثير كثير انه انا شغله
يمكن نعمل
يستغلوا الاطفائيه يا اللي مع الرياضيين
كثير
او اكثر من هيك ممكن تعملها بمستقبل
للامور العسكريه او حتى يستعملون مجال
الفضاء احنا اليوم تفاعل الجسم مع الاقمشه
هو تفاعل دوري كل النهار اذا كان ها الشيء
هيدي تجاوز حدود استعمالها لاستعمالات
اقوى من هيك اكيد كل الناس رحب تحبذ ها
الفتره هايدي
[موسيقى]
تحاول ان نفس المعنى ولكن القطاع نفسك في
البرنامج احنا موفقه الى الجزائر
في مشواري
كل واحد يتوقع نفسه يكون
عزيزتي حسينا طبيب العيون مهم وعيون البشر
اهم اختراع ك قد يقلص زياراتنا للطبيب
اهلا بك في فضاء العلوم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
كثير
بين جدا
سلامه هذا
الطفل يتفاعلوا بصعوبه مع طبيب
العيون
تريد صناعه
يقوم بفحص
الاطفال
[موسيقى]
الابتكار في نجوم العلوم ليس بحثا علميا
اكاديميا وكما رايت في التقارير الابتكار
النابع من حاجات الانسان وبالطبع فان
تنفيذ هذا العلوم سيدخل الفرحه الى قلوب
الكثيرين رواه المجلس الاجراميه لم تنتهي
المزيد من الرسائل بعد الفاصل
[موسيقى]
ام
التوتر العالي مفتوحه على حده الاقصى بعض
المشاركين يعيش خيبه الامل ونهايه الحلم
وهناك من انتصار تحقيق احلامه في اجنده
المجلس العلمي تحديدا سماء المنتشرين في
المجموعه الثانيه ولنقل قرار اللجنه
المشتركين بهذه المجموعه الابد الاختيار
وسيله تكنولوجيه مناسبه
[موسيقى]
ومك ازمه تكشف الان من
مغامرات بالعلوم
[موسيقى]
يعني كبير
محمد انه
معنا بس من العصبيه تاخذ بعض كوتيشن
اتمنى لك التوفيق ان شاء الله يعني رفع
مستوى
محمد هل اعطيني محمد سفر كان عليكم عليكم
السلام ذلك محمد الحمد لله رب العالمين ان
شاء الله ان توقع على يتوقع ان انت اللي
تكسر ولا
الحمد لله يعني الحمد لله رب العالمين
يعني حتكون فرحان سواء كتبت او خسر صحيح
مرحبا
مرحبا انا
كانت يعني مقتنع بال بال انتو بتسويه من
الاقتراع اكيد طبعا هذا الحق
طب انت متوقع ان تكسب محمد سليني والله
اللي فينا هو
ما عندي
الفلسطيني
ان ترتبط البعض في هذه الايام من شيء انا
اجي شعوره
ولهذا السبب الثاني محمد
شويه هيك
كانت شويه احترقت دكتور محمد انت ويشاركوا
جميل انتم الاثنين يعني ما بين معك مين
يفوز المهمه
صحيح اطلب منك تقول الوسام
[موسيقى]
مبروك الوسام
الذي ظل ما غير ذلك انت
[موسيقى]
المره
السلام
[موسيقى]
التنفيذ
اختراع جدا في مختلف يقدم في المجالس
العربيه والمؤتمرات ان يكون سياره واثنين
تحضير القهوه كثيره ومتنوعه
ولكن لا وجود له تقوم بصب القهوه العربيه
التقليديه
يريد صناعه الدله الروبوت بصب القهوه
العربيه الاصيله
[موسيقى]
الجامعه العربيه رمز ضيافه يعني مستحيله
تدخل المجلس
لما انت بعد ما يقول حياه المجلس والتي
عندنا كان قول الله تعالى عندنا من هذا
الرمز
[موسيقى]
الطريقه التقليديه
العرب العالم
من قلب ثقافتنا
العربيه
حتى خارج اطار المجلس
ثلاثه جزء من الترحيب
[موسيقى]
تفضل معنا ممكن اشارك في فكره ثانيه او
بنفس الفكره اه السنه الجايه او السنه
اللي بعدها والطول ما كنا احنا نقدم عليها
محمد
يكونوا هلا بوقت قريب صندوق
هذا الصندوق الافتراضي
انت هلا
الفين واثنين
بينما
التاثير يعني كل
انه هو الفائز حقول النتيجه
بطريقه جدا عليكم وعليكم السلام
خليك واقف محلك ما تتحرك
عيونك علي محمد الجفيري قضيه محمد الجفيري
الله يستر
محمد الجفيري معي هلا هلا هلا مرحبا عندما
محمد الجفيري من قطع انا معك محمد
محمود مشى بطريق
محمد ونظير
محمد
الاجراء كثير مثل ما مواقف نظيره
وانت محمد تدعي بانك
تدرب بالقياده صحيح فرجينا انتقاء لانك
انت بدك تبلغ ان كانت البرنامج ومحمد صدقي
ونظير راجعين على بلاده بطريقه قياديين
[موسيقى]
ام
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
انا اسف انه خليني اقول لك
لكن اه يعني اه هي هي بدايه حتى المشاريع
انشاء الله يوسف المحمود
اعطوني يعني مهمه صعبه ان اقول حق اللي
كانوا مع اي يعني ما حالفهم الحظ واتمنى
انه يعني يقدرون اه يسامحوني على ها الشيء
الخبر المعامل
لكن خرق فرحتها لها
اختراع موجه تحديدا
تعلم لغه الاشاره
امر معقد ومن للاطفال للصف وابتكار محمد
الجفيري هو ربط تفاعلي يعلم الاطفال الصمت
لغه الاشاره العربيه باسلوب موسى الوفاه
[موسيقى]
عبد الله الثاني الفين وخمسه يكون متاخر
فى الكلام في التربيه
اشاره تواصل تعلمت الاشاره
لغه الاشاره عشان تعلمها محتاج انك تكون
في قاعه الدرس الاستمرار المشكله الاساسيه
ولغايه اليوم انه ما
الشخص اللي بتعلم الوسيله الوحيده المتاحه
[موسيقى]
عريضه
التعامل مع المجتمع
الو مرحبا
محمد كراجه
مرحبا محمد
الحمد لله
ايه نعم معاك عندك ال اه الجهود اللي اللي
جبت معاك
موجود ثلثين
بدك تاخذه بتلبس تركه بالطياره وترجع الله
يسلمك
شكرا للاسف فرصه ثانيه انشاء الله انشاء
الله انشاء الله
انا ب كانت تجارب كثير حلو اه
الفرصه راح تجر بها وان شاء الله في السنه
اللي بعدها يعني الو محمد حمدان معاي
وبالضبط تمر اليوم الى ما كانت والله غير
موجود
غير موجود شوف شوف نظره وسيم وشوف نظره
شفيع رايك فيهم التوتر توتر
وانتظار
انتظارها توثر وانتظار ابيك تعطيني وسيله
او تفضل
قالوا
تاخذ محمد محمد حمدان
كان مفروض ياكل التمر اليوم لانه ما كله
للاسف انه ولازم يرجع يرجع الى بلاده اه
دكتور خالد كان لازم تمر اليوم وعشان هيك
ما مشي الحال
للاسف عندنا
والله اه بصفه عامه خيبه امل ان انه عندي
فرصه افضل لكن هي مش النهايه ابيك تعطيني
الو مرحبا
كيف حالك تمام
اسمع اسمع التوتر في صوره الكثير طبعا
الحين نحسن الموضوع بينك وبين
للاسف
بتقول انه هو اللي فاز بالمرحله السعوديه
[موسيقى]
ام
الرجال
ابدا والشباب اللي كانوا ما يعني عندهم
بروتين
وكانت
ام
انا كثير انه
المستشفيات
[موسيقى]
في المستشفيات
المرضى
[موسيقى]
على الكامله للعلاج
ووصول وجبات الطعام للمرضى في الوقت
المناسب
الخطه
المستشفى ممكن يساعدني ان اركز على الشغله
حتى
الابتكار ليس سهلا ويتطلب معارف علميه
وهو كما حد لايجاد حل للمشاكل يعيشها
الانسان يوميا من الواضح ان فرحه
الاشتراكي كبيره لكن هناك من ينتظر واعصاب
المشتركين الباقي ما زالت مربوطه خط
التوتر العالي
بقيه الرسائل المصيريه بعد الفاصل تابعونا
فيه عبر ستارز
وعبر مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي انستغرام
وتويتر
ام
[موسيقى]
واخيرا وليس اخرا المجموعه الثالثه من
سيبقى ومن سيغادر دكتور فؤاد المراد اعطاء
زخما كبيرا وانطلاقه متجدده لكل المبدعين
وهو بقيه الاعضاء سيقول النتيجه مباشره
لمن تبقى في قرار المجلس العلى
اللجنه تذهب الان بقرار المشتركين بقيه
القاعده فقط
والموقف ليس سهلا المره انا حاسس في احراج
اكبر لانه عالقليله في عشرين من بين
الثلاثه وثلاثين انا بصراحه ما
وحتى اخلاء تبرير ليش ما راح يفوتوا
الورشه
كلهم يعتبرون
يعني مجموعه يوصلوا للفاينل الان لذلك انا
بصراحه اليوم محرج
يعني مرتاح
[موسيقى]
يا احمد عبد الرحمان
هلا بدنا نبلش
شوي الجمود تنشا لانه النتيجه واحد من لكن
تاهلت ولا مرحله انه انتم فعلا خارج تحققه
هذه المنتجات هذه الاقتراحات هلا انتم
فعلا مخترعين ولكن ببرنامج والعلوم في
مقعد واحد من بين الاربعه بيكون ماشي
الحال
ان كسر الجمود انا شايف الجمهوريه
ارتاحوا ارتاحوا
النظرات الا غير
نظرات ليش لانه الرياضي بامتياز بيصير لنا
الجمود اعمل شيء حركه رياضيه اليوم
بالاستوديو اللي ما فيني ان او لابس بدله
انا مش
[تصفيق]
الروح الرياضيه بدي اكثر منها
معنا ببرنامج
وانشاء الاوسط
هلا انا بدي اشوف في عندنا من تج تعليمي
فيه عندي كمان
فيه ينكر اهميه الطب ان نطلع البريس
الطبيب وانا شايف انه مانا بحاجه
[موسيقى]
سياسي السكر لانه ما زالت في مرحله بحوث
انت مخترع لازم تكفي اكيد ولكن
تسعه كراسي برنامج نجوم العلوم الظاهر كل
اللجنه قطعت انه فيه فرصه افضل لحد اخر
اوكي وان فعلا لو فيه ثلاثه وثلاثين مقعد
بورش هجوم العلوم انا احب بانه ثلاثه
وثلاثين يفوتوا بس للاسف فيه
خارج المركز اكيد اكيد الشغله على حالها
خلص القادم اه وان شاء الله
وبقيت ما بين احمد
لما اجا الدكتور فؤاد كان الارتباك اكثر
بكثير من ان فكره المغلفات تعليم وصحه مين
بدو تعليم
[تصفيق]
الصحه
وانا
يعني
الحمد لله
المجال
خلال العمليات الجراحيه
يضطر الطبيب الى ايقاف العمليه عده مرات
من الشوائب
تلقائيا لتحسين
احيانا
في العمليات الجراحيه
في كل مره
ثانيه وهذا
العمليه
عندي انا
ان يكون نظيف
العمليه
مساء الخير
اه وان شاء الله في اربعه واحد منكم حيفضل
وثلاثه
اوكي
طبعا يعني كنت محتاج الاختراع الطريق اللي
محتاجين فكرنا نعرج على السوبر ماركت لنا
كل سياق فكرنا فيك سعاده واجهت المشكله
اللي بكل بحكي عنها وجهنا المشكله تحكي
عنها
احمد
هايدا الشمس والحراره
[ضحك]
يعني
يعني اكثر من مشروع الله
جاهز
واحد ثلاثه
ايضا اليوم مع انهم الله
اسعد الله
نعم
[موسيقى]
ام
اذن جميله مبروك بالتوفيق
اقتراحاتكم وتكمل ومصلحتكم
حاله لكن الحمد لله اللهم لك الحمد يعني
فخور ان شاء الله يعني مش راح يمشي بينجح
ب يخدم كثيرا ان شاء الله من الناس
ساعه كثير من في مكه ما بضيع ان شاء الله
خلال الحرب خلال موسم الحج يظل الكثيرون
طريقهم بسبب كبرى المكان و عدد الحجاج
لتسهيل مناسك الحج افتكر مشعل سوارا يوجه
المؤمن داخل المباني وخارجها في مكه
المكرمه
[موسيقى]
الحج فريضه على المسلمين
التزايد في الاقبال على تاديه
يتزايد سنه
منطقه الحج كبيره جدا من احدى الصعوبات
التي تواجه الحديث باسم الحزب هو الوصول
الى الاماكن المحدده كثيرون من الحجيج لا
يعرفون العوده التاهيل خيمهم بالاخص في
بعض منهم كبار السن مش مدرك العمران بتاع
المكان صعب جدا هو يوصل الى جر وبتاع ما
هو سعود الضائع وما هو شعور اهله
هناك شاف يعمل لتيسير امور الناس هذا
الضائع لا يعرف ان يعبر عن مكان تاره ياخذ
وقت يوم او يومين من العوده الى بيروت في
انا اتمنى ان اجد قريبا وان نسخر كل انواع
التكنولوجيا من اجل تقديم الراحه للانسان
وان يعينه على اداء في عباداته وسلامه
عمره وحياته
الله
برنامج نجوم العلوم هذه فرصه ذهبيه للشباب
العربي تعتبر منصه على مستوى العالم هذه
المنصه لما يوقف عليها الشعب العربي بين
العالم انه العالم العربي لا زال فيه ناس
مبتكرين على مستوى تاريخنا القديم اللي
يعترف فيه كل العالم
السلام عليكم السلام مرحبا بك زينب مرحبا
بك محمد مرحبا بك عبد الرحمان مرحبا اه
كيف تحسون
ولا
حماس عبد الرحمان
يساعدك
بيساعد كل الناس ان شاء الله كل واحد
المستفيدين احب ان ارحب بكم واقول لكم
يعني انت وصلت الى هذه المرحله هاذي انتم
ثلاثه وثلاثين من اكثر من الف يعني وصلت
داخل ال اربعه في المائه من التصفيات بس
لازم احنا نوصلها الى داخل ال واحد في
المائه فليس والحق في منكم اثنين
بيرجع الى بيته اليوم
[موسيقى]
يا محمد
للاسف
انت مش بتكون من داخل الواحد شكرا لك
اه الحمد لله يعني هو الوصول لها المرحله
بحد ذاته انجاز كل يوصلوا لهون ثلاثه
وثلاثين عند الابتكارات طريق وهي فرصه
يعني فرصه الاخر واحد يطلع بالاخير مشترك
اللي حصل عليه الحين وصلنا بين زينب وبين
عبد الرحمان لو ما كانت مسابقه كانها
الثلاثه وثلاثين اخذنا هم كلهم
زينب مبروك
الى مرحله الصعود
شكرا لك عبد الرحمان
[موسيقى]
فرحه كبيره
اه وان شاء الله ن في البحر
الناس
تاكد من وجود الكاس راح يتم الينا الكبيره
باستخدام المواد الاوليه
[موسيقى]
يحتاج والدقه العاليه والخطا البشري
وخيبه تريد زينه
بناء جهاز يجبروا اليه الاطراف المكسوره
[موسيقى]
السياره
السوري مثلا عم تحكي معملنا صوره
العدل
ايدين ان احنا عملنا الصوره طلعت
تعرف ان الغرب بيصيروا تهيمن قرار اذا
قدرت ما كانت حتى واحد بالمائه
الاختراعات اللي تاهلت لهذا الموسم انا
فخور فيها
وحابب قدما للعالم كله مش بس العالم
العربي لانه انا متاكد تسعه الله راد راح
يفوتوا يدخلوا هذه
الورشه ورشه نجوم العلوم رقم تسعه راح
يكون الريم عالميا وب تنافسيه درجه
تنافسيه كثير عاليه انه العالم العربي
يفتخر فيها في شباب متعلمين وفي شباب يسخر
ونعلم وكتب وفي مؤسسه من المؤثر قطر عم
تعطي فرصه ذهبيه لا مثيل له قلب العرب
[موسيقى]
المجلس العلمي قال كلمته تسعه يستعدون
لخوض المغامرات العلميه في مختبرات نجوم
العلوم الاسبوع المقبل تبدا تحديات
وتوصيات علميه جديده سنتابعها سوريا
تابعونا عبر موقعنا
ومواقع تواصل اجتماعي فيس بوك انستقرام
وتويتر الان استودعكم الله مثل معنا على
الوضع دائما في امان الله
[موسيقى]